[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Brittany O'Grady
and Nat wolf who star in the consultant
which is on Prime video today how you
guys doing today we're good great man
we're so happy to be talking about this
show oh yeah I'm happy to be talking to
you guys absolutely love this show I'm
excited for one to see it and how like
thrilling it is and one of the things
that sticks out to me is actually with
Brittany with this role you're playing
the most iconic creative liaison we've
seen on screen today so was there any
job experiences in your life you drew
from to like prepare for that
um you know I kind of Drew more on
people in my life who
maybe were in environments like that or
maybe what I would be like if I was in a
in an office space uh and so I have a
lot of people around me who you know
have a line a career path that aligns
more with
I don't know an assistant or creative
liaison or something like that so uh I
guess I just let my imagination
uh yeah no
I love that answer and I love that
you're observing things around you to
bring for the role that's pretty cool
and uh Nat there's some intense
sequences in this show with you and
Kristoff Waltz was it even more intense
filming those scenes knowing that your
scene partner was Kristoff Waltz Across
From You No it's it's like I was saying
it's like um being on the same
basketball team as LeBron James you're
just like God I'm on this team that how
did I get so lucky to be you know
anytime I don't know where I am on the
court I'll just pass in the ball oh yeah
I love that and then it rubs off onto
you that's that's a great answer I like
the basketball analogies it's good and
uh Brittany I love watching you and not
play detective together at certain parts
in this show I think it was my favorite
thing about the show so first show
that's like a mystery though did you
like pretend you didn't know what
happens when you get into that like or
did you not read ahead too far or ask
questions do you keep the mystery for
yourself uh yeah we were given the
scripts as we went along so it did kind
of keep the mystery we we had an idea of
kind of had a compass like we knew what
direction it was going in but we didn't
know specifically what was going to
happen so it was a lot of fun to kind of
figure out and piece together and it was
so much information I feel like once we
watched it back everything it was like
all the puzzle pieces were put back
together and it was some of the like it
was so so fun to do that with that we
had a really good time because you know
sometimes when you're trying to describe
the story where it's going it can be
really
just like
just kind of very clear yeah well it's
crazy with this show the writing is so
good that the exposition of the
detective Exposition is some of the most
fun scenes I've ever done like they're
all they're so they're banter and
they're and it's so elevated and funny
and interesting and and there's such a
rhythm to it and it's Musical and
um there's a there the the those are
scenes usually dread doing you know but
these I was so excited also working with
Brittany it's just like uh it was it we
would get the scripts and we would call
each other and just get so excited
either God can you see what we get to do
in this but you know yeah no and that's
also a tribute to you guys too you bring
that to life and it makes it exciting to
watch and like Bernie you're alluding to
just going back I feel like people are
going to want to watch this one twice
even episodes twice just to catch so
much stuff so really good job by you
guys with that and
Brittany too with the huge moment that
the White Lotus is having people are
still watching season one for the first
time so did you like ever imagine when
you got the part of that show that
people would still like be talking about
that you're still getting feedback for
it today no I didn't know that it was
going to be the wave that it was I had
no idea and I think it uh you know I've
been working a while but that was the
one job that I think kind of put me on
the map for some people that you know uh
didn't see my work before so I'm really
grateful for that experience and
um yeah I can I'm very happy for Mike
White and everybody involved
yeah no and you do amazing in that too
so really really cool and excited to see
that your career just like flourish with
that and that I'm gonna have to answer
the question I always want someone to
answer for me but if this show gets
picked up for a season two which it will
do you binge the first season before
jumping onto set for the next season
that's such a great question I
don't know I haven't done since I was
okay
but I I think I think I would have to I
mean I mean we were so locked into that
World
um and and my guess is it we kind of
picked up where we left off and so yeah
I think I would have to oh I love the
honesty in that answer so good yeah so
let's hope it gets picked up so you can
binge it again Watch Britney and that
crush it and again solid on Prime video
today it's such a fun show thank you
guys for joining me hope to talk to you
thank you so much